why communism is even worse than fascism
I'm aware that if you follow our Channel
you understand nuance and complexity but
sadly not everyone does in view of this
I have to make this disclaimer for those
who will inevitably attempt to
misrepresent what I'm saying in the
future nothing I'm about to say is
intended to serve as a defense of
fascism arguing about whether fascism is
better than communism is like fighting
over your preferred flavor of gangrene I
merely ask that those of you who are
poor fascism as much as I do are also
willing to be intellectually honest and
recognize the fact that communism is in
fact even worse I met a Bulgarian man in
an Amsterdam Cafe earlier this week he
recognized me and we talk about many
things he asked me if I tin Chernobyl
the HBO miniseries and I said no because
I hate watching stuff everyone's banging
on about he said I know what you mean
but you must watch it because it
perfectly captures the society we lived
in where fear and cowardice triumphs
over truth I watched Chernobyl the day I
got home and he's right the series is so
authentic it means immediately hits you
in the gut when you recognize her but he
also told me a fascinating story about
his country that I was not aware of the
man who eventually became the first
president of Bulgaria when the USSR
collapsed jealous was a dissident during
Soviet times he was expelled from the
Communist party and made unemployable
for years eventually in 1982 he wrote a
book called fascism in which he
chronicled the fascist regimes in Spain
Italy and Germany before during and
after World War II was this a ploy to
Curry favor with the Communist Party by
criticizing its enemies not exactly the
book was banned within weeks of
publication because the similarities
between the societies he described in
the book and the one he lived in were
far too striking to ignore the parallels
between these two collectivist
ideologies are of course exceedingly
obvious spawned during the same time
period as a response to the same problem
and offering many of the same Solutions
Communists and fascists had Stark
differences but on economics in
particular hit Hitler's National
socialists were not as different to
other kinds of socialists as people
would like to believe the reasons for
this historical revisionism differ from
country to Country in Russia where I
come from a law passed in 2014
criminalized any meaningful comparison
between the crimes of the Soviet Union
and the exact same crimes committed by
Nazi Germany as a result most people in
Russia and frankly elsewhere have no
idea that when Hitler started World War
II by invading Poland he wasn't alone
the Soviet Union invaded Poland at
exactly the same time capturing more
territory than the Germans this was the
product of an explicit albeit secret
agreement between Hitler and Stalin in
which they divided Eastern Europe as
they saw fit something called the
molotov ribbon truck pact Ironically in
Russia which experienced communism
firsthand the comparison between
communism and fascism is not banned in
order to defend the ideology of
Communism merely to protect the
historical view of Russians as a good
people who sacrificed millions of lives
to stop Hitler which is of course true
in the way best on the other hand
communism apologists operate from a
rather different set of needs first
despite what historian Roger moorhouse
calls the devil's alliance between Nazi
Germany and the USSR Hitler soon stabbed
his new friend in the back and by June
1941 having been invaded the Soviets
found themselves on the same side as
Britain and France fighting Germany
Orwell's magnificent preface to Animal
Farm makes clear the corrosive effect
this necessary Alliance had on the
West's ability to criticize communism
you may be familiar with the following
Orwell quote I'm well acquainted with
all the arguments against freedom of
thought and speech the arguments which
claim that it cannot exist and the
arguments which claimed that it ought
not to I answer simply that they don't
convince me and that our civilization
over a period of 400 years has been
founded on the opposite notice what you
likely aren't familiar with is the
sentence that followed it which was for
quite a decade past I have believed that
the existing Russian regime is a mainly
evil thing and I claimed the right to
say so in spite of the fact that we are
allies with the USSR in a war which I
want to see one the argument for
preventing this sort of sentiment from
being aired was simple we needed the
Soviet Union to win the war and shutting
up Stalin's critics was a price worth
paying in other words some white washing
of communist crimes is a product of
practical considerations but not all
there were and I can tell you from
direct personal experience still are
many people in Western societies who are
temperamentally inclined towards the
Allure of radical socialism as they see
the negative tradeoffs of capitalism
their instincts for compassion empathy
and Care kick into overdrive combined
with an idealism which blinds them to
the sad truth of life that any society
will always have unsolvable problems
they see only the flaws in their own and
assume that the opposite must be better
George Bernard Shaw for example loved
communism and worshiped Stalin Walter
Durante of the New York Times won a
Pulitzer Prize for his fraudulent
coverage of the holiday more and
widespread famine in the Soviet Union in
which Millions starve to death including
members of my own family I won't waste
your time with more examples we all know
some on the left cover for communism
because they believe in it or want to
believe it hasn't been tried properly
nor will I give you the standard
anti-communist talking points about the
death toll from communist regimes which
far exceeds those of any other ideology
I want to remind you that Che Guevara
whose face is an ever-present symbol of
resistance around the world was in fact
nothing more than a racist homophobic
mass murderer above and beyond these
very real atrocities the true horror of
the Communist system was something that
went beyond its material impact as my
newly made Bulgarian friend told me
Bulgaria has a difficult history he said
constantly invaded occupied by the
Ottomans for centuries and we always
bounce back but we still haven't
recovered from communism why because
while fascism is nationalistic
totalitarian and collectivist it does
not aspire to dominate the lives of
ordinary citizens to anything like this
extent communism remember rejected the
idea of private property private
Enterprise or indeed a private life of
any kind in the Soviet Union you were
explicitly told to put the interests of
the state above not only your own but
those of your loved ones if you read my
book and immigrant's love letter to the
West you'll remember the story of pablic
marozov a boy who reported his own
father to the authorities and was held
up as a national hero fascism was almost
as evil as communism to be sure but it
did not attempt to achieve its aims by
stealing and redistributing private
property seizing your business or
installing a new tyrannical hierarchy
under the pretense of eradicating it the
fear and deceit you see depicted so
accurately in the Chernobyl miniseries
is a product of a society that has
fundamentally broken the will of its own
people the drive to better your own life
to see your children prosper and Thrive
to create and build things worthy of
notice and admiration all of these were
beaten starved and tortured out of the
people who had the misfortune to live
under communist
so yes communist societies did Kill star
of rape and torture more people than the
fascist but they also engaged in the
totalitarianism of the mind of the kind
and not even Hitler aspired to it is for
this reason above all others that those
of us who lived under communism or come
from families that did reject so
strongly the Modern Trend in which
ideology is elevated above truth
political correctness is prioritized
over facts and the powers that be
increasingly seek to control not only
what we do but also what we think
[Music]
good